bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo au palais mickaël
szames s bonjour jour où elle dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
cette semaine les suites de l'affairé
strauss kahn avec la mise en cause de la
crédibilité de l'accusé certains proches
évoquent de nouveau la possibilité du
complot d'autres se prennent à rêver du
retour de dsk
mais en france d'autres soucis attendait
est ce qu'avec une plainte pour
tentative de viol déposée par tristane
banon
travailler plus pour partir à la
retraite le ministre du travail xavier
bertrand a confirmé l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation 41 ans et demi au
lieu de 41 ça mignon ainsi sur
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie à
décret doit être signé dans les
prochaines semaines enfin l'ump les
attaques sur le terrain de l'immigration
avec une convention consacrée aux sujets
et 22 propositions pour réaffirmer les
principes d'une immigration choisie
claude guillon qui était présent a
réaffirmé son intention de limiter
l'immigration légale est avec nous votre
plateau notre invité pour commenter
toute cette actualité politique rachida
dati bonjour mon jeu merci d'être venus
députée européenne et maire du 7e
arrondissement de paris et ancienne
garde des sceaux sous le gouvernement de
françois fillon que vous avez quitté en
2009 d'ailleurs vous ne cachez pas vos
ambitions pour paris notamment devenir
député c'est quelque chose que vous
aimeriez mais tout ça évidemment on va
reparler car face à vous vous pourriez
avoir notamment françois filet alors
vous avez publié il ya quelques semaines
votre autobiographie fille de m barek et
de fatim-zohra vous y parlez de votre
famille de votre parcours également des
journalistes l'avaient fait avant vous
de façon pas toujours très tendre
ça n'est pas fréquente publié une
biographie une autobiographie quand on
est cadre à est-ce que c'était une façon
un peu de répliquer à ces critiques
tout d'abord c'est pas c'est pas du tout
une autobiographie parce que je pense
que nous sommes quand même plus
importante que ça c'est ce livre est un
récit sur les convictions sur mes idées
sur mon militantisme qui date bien avant
le fait d'avoir été garde des sceaux et
puis il faut savoir aussi que c'est vrai
vous avez raison de le mentionner de
nombreux livres ont été écrits qui était
qui contenait des ragots des calomnies
des témoignages anonymes
et puis parfois même ils délivrent ou
s'ils ont été écrits très jolie
indiquant presque ma vie est un conte de
fées ça n'était pas du tout le cas non
plus donc ça me permet de rétablir à
rétablir certaines vérités serre que
dans ce livre j'explique là où j'ai
contribué à la campagne présidentielle
les engagements que j'ai tenus comme une
injustice mais combat d'avant-hier
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui mais aussi les
combats que je mène encore aujourd'hui
donc c'est plutôt un peu un rapport
d'étape une mise au point
les rencontres les parcours c'est un peu
ce que vous évoquez la soul mais c'est
un livre
je considère que c'est un livre que
plein d'optimisme et d'espoir c'est de
dire que la france permet un parcours
comme le mien c'est dire que c'est
possible mais je dis aussi que ce n'est
pas très facile alors la semaine
dernière le week-end dernier très
précisément vous êtes allés au mariage
du prince albert à monaco et puis la
veille vous étiez en déplacement dans
les alpes de haute provence
vous êtes allé voir les éleveurs quel
est le moment que vous avez préféré
entre ces deux moments mais j'ai passé
une journée à sisteron et ses alentours
le vendredi j'ai passé toute la journée
et daniel spagnou qui est un un député
rural c'était j'étais allé il ya
quelques mois j'avais dit que je
reviendrais au moment de la transhumance
ça m'a permis aussi de discuter que les
éleveurs qui défendent la qualité
évidemment deux de leurs agneaux
l'agneau de sisteron qui est un label
dans un contexte un peu de faits comme
cole est alors rempli alors merci non
mais le reste s'est mis non mais c'est
marrant vous réduisez toujours les
choses et des aspects privé on n'avait
pas vu voilà j'en ai pas fait et à la
ddsp privée je vais pas vous dire aussi
ce que je fais dans le cas de ma vie
privée
ma vie politique mon engagement c'est
aussi d'être aux côtés des éleveurs
comme député européen mais aussi comme
responsable politique donc je vous
décris ma journée auprès des éleveurs de
sisteron avec daniel spagnou qui est un
milieu rural d'une grande qualité qui
est un ami au passage on va défiler
toute la semaine rachida dati lundi
nouveau tournant dans l' affaire dsk
l'hypothèse du complot ont refait
surface
en ce lundi en effet les coulisses
politique bruisse des retournements
spectaculaires de la sphère dominique
strauss kahn le bureau du procureur lui
même a donc révélé les failles de
l'accusation est déjà un petit noyau
proche de dominique strauss kahn fait
resurgir l'idée d'un complot
yoann cela après le rebondissement
judiciaire place à la contre attaque
politique
depuis ce week end certains proches de
dominique strauss kahn s'interroge sur
d'éventuelles manipulations à l'encontre
de l'ex patron du fmi dans le
collimateur de michèle sabban
vice-présidente du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france la proximité supposée
entre le chef de l'état et est le chef
de la police de new york ainsi que le
rôle de la direction du sofitel dans
lequel dsk séjournait ce qui est quand
même quelque chose qui va pas bien il ya
le sofitel le commissaire de police de
new york qui a été décoré je crois de la
légion d'honneur par nicolas sarkozy il
ya peu de temps
reprises depuis hier ces théories qui
met en cause les autorités françaises ne
fait pas l'unanimité y compris chez les
proches de l'ancien patron du fmi
ce matin pierre moscovici a ouvertement
pris ses distances avec ces accusations
que le ministre de l'intérieur qualifie
pour sa part d' insinuations
voici quelques semaines toute la france
a condamné des propos de luc ferry qui
mettait en cause un ancien ministre pour
des pratiques pédophiles qui auraient
été commises au maroc et tout le monde a
dit c'est scandaleux parce que quand on
sait on dit on affirme ont saisi la
justice
on ne procède pas par insinuations eh
bien là c'est la même chose
parmi les premiers à s'interroger sur le
rôle des dirigeants du sofitel de new
york
le député socialiste françois loncle
maintient ses propos et demande
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur la façon
dont les autorités françaises ont été
informées
il n'y a aucune accusation il n'y a
aucune insinuations je demande qu'on
établisse la vérité
par exemple le fait de savoir si paris a
été averti avant
ou après l'arrestation de dominique
strauss kahn c'est intéressant en
l'absence d'éléments à charge
le ps entend pour sa part faire preuve
de prudence si l' affaire dsk ressemble
de plus en plus à une erreur judiciaire
rien ne prouve jusqu'à présent qu'il
s'agit d'un complot politique
la rachida dati à l'idée d'un complot ou
d'un piège vous sembler totalement
loufoque
moi j'ai été avant d'être garde des
sceaux j'étais magistrat j'ai toujours
dit laissant prospérer la procédure
judiciaire
pour l'instant les charges sont pas
remises en cause les chefs d'inculpation
n'ont pas été remis en cause non plus la
procédure est toujours en cours sur que
c'est pas parce qu'on a allégé des
mesures de jaillir de contrôle
judiciaire ou de survie en judiciaire
que que la procédure est terminée donc
attendons l'issue de cette procédure
judiciaire dans la gauche de créer au
complot comme on l'a vu dans la bouche
elle peut crier à tout ce qu'elle veut
un peu de décence
voilà attendons l'issue de cette
procédure judiciaire et lille et d'un
piège n'est pas forcément avec un peu de
décence ne lisez nos c'est pas l'idée
d'un fils soit arrêter d'être dans des
fantasmes absolument inacceptable il ya
une procédure judiciaire qui concerne
une personnalité donc on peut attendre
l'issue de cette procédure judiciaire ce
que vous pensez que le procureur cyrus
vance et allez un petit peu trop vite
dans la procédure notamment en demandant
l'inculpation très rapidement avant même
de mener une enquête comme le système
américain pouvait le permettre il a
respecté les règles de la procédure
judiciaire
ensuite il a fait vérifier les éléments
à charge qu'ils pouvaient avoir
il a nuancé effectivement certaines
charges mais il ne les a pas remise en
cause
système américain c'est un système qui
vous plaît finalement par rapport à ce
que je vous dis je ne porterai pas c'est
un pays souverain avec une justice
indépendance je vais quand même pas
aller porter un jugement sur la question
du jeu vous dire c'est que je vais pas
porter un jugement sur un système que
les américains souhaitent approuve c'est
leur système judiciaire dans leur pays
qui est en totale indépendance
je dis simplement que je préfère le
système judiciaire que nous avons en
tant que française mais je n'ai pas à
porter un jugement sur un système qui
est souhaité par les américains
procureur est élu notamment comme c'est
le cas puisque cyrus 27 ans campagne ça
peut orienter son enquête
j'en sais rien je dis simplement que le
système judiciaire
il est en france moi je prescrire notre
organisation judici donc ça redore un
peu le la fonction de juge d'instruction
non c'est marrant parce que vous faites
tout en creux de ce sont deux systèmes
totalement différent oui mais c'est pas
mais comme dans tous les systèmes
il ya des avantages et des inconvénients
du système américain comme dans le nôtre
voilà il ya peu à dire que ceux de dire
trop lourd par exemple sinon c'est ça
veut rien dire d'avoir des procédures
trop long iliad il ya des affaires qui
mérite du temps pourquoi parce que la
justice doit enquêter doit rechercher la
vérité dans la sérénité
parfois il faut plus de temps parfois il
faut beaucoup moins de temps pour la
justice des mineurs
c'est vrai que moi je d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que une partie a été adopté moi
je serais plutôt partisans d'avoir une
justice plus rapide pour les mineurs
pourquoi parce que la notion du temps
pour un mineur tout à moins un mineur
délinquant n'est absolument pas le même
qu effectivement pour un majeur donc le
temps pour la justice parfois c'est
bénéfique de prendre du temps pour c'est
dans l'intérêt de la recherche de la
vérité est parfois faut aller très vite
la justice américaine
au moins se remet assez facilement en
cause et plus rapidement on l'a vu dans
cette affaire puisque le procureur a de
lui-même parlé des failles dans le
système de l'accusation
il n'a pas remis en cause enfin le
jugement n'a pas été rendu et les
charges n'ont pas été remises en cause
donc elle sait où c'est comme dire que
c'est comme une enquête en france
vous avez une plainte parfois la plainte
les éléments de la plainte peuvent être
effectivement atténué mais ça ne remet
pas en cause ni enquête ni même la
qualification de la qualification pénale
la qualification des faits c'est ce qui
se passe aux etats unis
je ne crois pas que les chefs
d'inculpation soit tombé ou qu'une seule
charge et été enlevée donc faut faire
attention à ce qu'on dit ou à la manière
de l'expliquer dire que c'est pas nous
sommes pas le même système le procureur
vient expliquer publiquement que dans le
contenu de la plainte il ya des éléments
qui sont qui ont été peut être sujet à
caution
les points mais oui d'accord mais ce
n'est pas à nous d'en c'est tous les
jours dans les enquêtes que en france
dans les enquêtes qui sont menées
il ya des éléments dans l'est des
plaintes qui sont revus remis en cause
ou objectivement accentuée mais ça ne
remet pas en cause la qualification des
fêtes qui effectivement s'est passé aux
états unis alors la justice américaine
d'une part la justice française aussi
qui pourrait s'intéresser à dominique
strauss kahn
une autre plainte est venu s'ajouter
cette fois en france tristane banon
romancière journaliste aujourd'hui âgé
de 32 ans accuse dominique strauss kahn
de tentative de viol
ces faits remonteraient à 2003 se
seraient déroulés dans un appartement
parisien
le parquet a décidé d'ouvrir une enquête
préliminaire ça veut dire que donc il y
aura peut-être une plainte qui sera
jugée de crédit par le parquet les
ennuis judiciaires de dominique
strauss-kahn sont loin d'être terminée
notamment en france oui alors toujours
attendre quoi peut-être sur l'avenir de
dominique strauss kahn c'est à l'avenir
politique
d'abord il n'a pas encore été condamnés
donc non mais il ya le restera toujours
quelque chose
il n'y a pas de condamnation donc
attendons et quand bien même en
politique si vous n'avez pas on vous
enlève pas vos droits civiques vos
droits civils autres vous pouvez
toujours faire de la politique après ses
leçons une décision personnelle de
dominique strauss kahn est ensuite c'est
un choix j'allais dire des militants
socialistes des socialistes pour ne pas
dire les électeurs qui effectivement
adhérents et des rampes à souhaiteront
qu'il revienne qu'il reste ou qu'il ne
reste pas ça c'est c'est pas que je vous
dise une procédure en cours laissant
prospérer les procédures judiciaires en
cours
allez on va passer au mardi avec
justement martine aubry qui conforte sa
candidature à la primaire socialiste
martine aubry devraient elles s'effacer
en cas de retour de dominique strauss
kahn la question paraît sinon saugrenue
du moins très prématuré en ce mardi
cependant la candidate réuni ses troupes
à l'assemblée et fait savoir que
dominique strauss kahn lui aurait
confirmé son intention de rester en
retrait quoi qu'il arrive
céline bittner peu importe ce qui se
passe à new york martine aubry veut
montrer qu'elle ne renoncera pas à sa
candidature et que la primaire se joue
ici à paris aujourd'hui elle a réuni une
centaine de parlementaires pour un
déjeuner prévu avant la libération de
dsk
objectif organiser ces trous ce n'est
pas une démonstration de force c'est
simplement un rassemblement qui
s'opèrent qui s'opère plus en plus
largement autour martine aubry et qui
montrent par là qu'elle a cette capacité
à rassembler très largement autour
d'elle derrière ces fenêtres lors du
déjeuner martine aubry n'aurait pas
évoqué un éventuel retour de dominique
strauss kahn dans la primaire socialiste
la candidate veut éviter que cette
affaire empoisonne de sa campagne
ces soutiens préfère d'ailleurs évité le
sujet
pas franchement on va continuer à parler
de ça on fait un objet de faire de la
politique malheureusement pas de la
fiction on n'écrit pas un roman mais
pourtant selon le journal le monde lors
d'un coup de fil entre martine aubry et
dominique strauss kahn l'ancien patron
du fmi lui aurait signifié qu'il n'avait
pas l'intention de se présenter à la
primaire
une information démentie par les proches
de dsk
aujourd'hui dominique strauss kahn
attend la décision définitive de la
justice américaine qui va proclamer
semble-t-il dans quelques jours son
innocence il reviendra ensuite pour
s'expliquer devant les français
toute autre déclaration me semble
extrêmement prématuré
les proches de dominique strauss-kahn
qui ne veulent pas fermer la porte à
leur mentor
quant aux soutiens de martine aubry ils
veulent désormais passer à l'action que
leur championne rentre enfin réellement
en campagne rachida dati vous qui êtes
de l'autre côté avec quel oeil
regardez-vous toutes les complications
pour les primaires des socialistes
l'ombre de dominique strauss kahn qui
plane dans un sens ou dans un autre
les primaires après tout c'est un mode
de désignation d'un candidat à une
élection importante c'est pas une
élection à la légère moi je limite que
quelqu'un prenne du temps de réflexion
qu'il hésite qui ne soit pas sûr c'est
pas une élection anodine c'est pas un
casting c'est pas la star academy de
vous faire moi je trouve ça finalement
légitime c'est l'or c'est leur choix
ensuite moi je compte quand je vois tous
ces candidats toutes ces personnalités
de gauche c'est quand même bien des
enfants gâtés
il n'a pas un fin franchement moi je
trouve que c'est indécent vis à vis des
français
une élection présidentielle c'est son
pays c'est quand même le sort des
français c'est quand même leurs
conditions de vie c'est s'occuper leurs
préoccupations franchement c'est des
bagarres d'enfants gâtés
moi je vous dire si c'est ça la
politique ça donne pas très envie on
peut comprendre que les français parfois
en soient écoeurés pour ne pas dire
exaspérer la garde d'enfant gâté en même
temps une primaire est un combat donc
une primaire est un combat c'est un
combat de deux personnes sur endroit ils
combattent dire moi sur dire comment on
sort notre pays de la crise comment on
lutte contre le chômage des jeunes
comment réformer notre système éducatif
comment met en oeuvre une politique
ambitieuse enfin une vraie politique
d'intégration qui n'entend pas beaucoup
sur ces sujets donc franchement c'est à
exaspérer écoeuré les français la
politique du primaire qui est à remettre
en cause
peut-être aussi
ces personnalités faudrait peut-être
aussi qu'il a eu un petit peu met les
mains dans le charbon l'arrêt dans le
cambouis bien de temps en temps ça leur
ferait du bien de savoir comment vivent
les français
vous avez dit que l'ump avait dit et
notamment nicolas sarkozy à propos de
toute cette affaire autour de dominique
strauss kahn que le ps avait perdu perdu
la bataille de la morale parce que sur
les ssii vous l'a dit il l'a fait savoir
en tout cas au milieu des échos dans la
presse zico d'accord la morale elle est
valable pour tout le monde c'est la
sphère de dominique strauss kahn à
l'impact pas que le parti socialiste est
la pratique la politique on refait la
pac toute la vie politique française
c'est pour ça que faut faire attention
ne pas tirer des jugements hâtifs et de
tout généralisée c'est la politique
c'est c'est pas que ça
donc cette affaire devient une affaire
privée mais c'est vrai que cette affaire
impacte l'ensemble de la vie politique
française qui demanderont les français
demanderons de nous beaucoup plus
d'exemplarité et plus de cohérence dans
ce qu'on dit en ce qu'on fait dans la
menace en vie est ce que nous nous
proposons pour améliorer la vie des
français que tout le monde y perd de la
crédibilité y compris à droite ne s'est
pas de c'est pas qu'on y perd de la
crédibilité c'est que les français
seront encore plus exigeants vis-à-vis
des responsables politiques
il ya aussi avance sur martine aubry
c'est une candidate sérieuse face
notamment à nicolas sarkozy il a jugé
comme martine aubry
j'ai pas à porter de jugement de valeur
sur sa personne c'est une personne tout
à fait respectable quand je connais
d'ailleurs mais maintenant ce qu'ils
proposent
bon à savoir ce qu'ils proposent l'avait
dit nota voir la presse angers une table
au filet rouge c'était la politique des
années 80 bah oui les emplois jeunes
la police de proximité plus de dépenses
publiques augmentation des impôts j'ai
connu mois leur politique de la ville
nous avait posé sur une mer énorme ce
qu'ils en ont oui mais c'était un projet
c'est un projet de législature c'est pas
un projet de candidat la preuve c'est
que manuel valls s'en éloigne montebourg
s'en éloigne complètement et martine
aubry n'a pas encore dit ce qu'elle
prenait dedans donc c'est pas un
programme de candidat socialiste mais ce
qui a dans cette plateforme dire que les
emplois jeunes on a vu les résultats moi
je m'en parlez vous renvoie au livre que
j'ai écrit parce que je fais tout
uniquement une partie sur fectivement
ces emplois jeunes sur les dégâts que ça
a pu faire sur sur certains jeunes et
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
donc moi je voudrais pas qu'on
recommence ces mêmes dégâts autre sujet
cette fois parler des retraites mardi
toujours le goût
le mans s'apprête à publier un décret
qui allonge la durée de cotisation pour
l'obtention d'une retraite à taux plein
une annonce qui tombe quelques jours
seulement après l'entrée en vigueur du
passage de 60 à 62 ans de l'âge légal du
départ à la retraite
des annonces qui se télescopent et qui
ont fait réagir sur les bancs de
l'assemblée des explications d'hélène
manger rni
c'est loin d'être une surprise il faudra
travailler encore plus longtemps
quarante et une années et demi de
cotisations c'est le nouveau palier à
atteindre pour la génération 1955 qui
veut avoir une retraite à taux plein
c'est tout simplement l'application de
la loi de 2003 qui était portée à
l'époque par françois fillon j'étais le
rapporteur de ce texte et nous ne
faisons qu'appliquer les textes pourquoi
parce que nous vivons aujourd'hui plus
longtemps il est logique qu'on travaille
un peu plus longtemps
cette évolution inéluctable est prévue
par la loi votée l'année dernière dans
l'hémicycle mais le gouvernement
accélère la manoeuvre cet allongement de
la durée de cotisation était prévue à
l'horizon 2020 seulement c'est donc
beaucoup plus rapide que prévu les
députés de gauche saisissent l'occasion
de dénoncer une nouvelle fois la réforme
2010 une réforme qui pour eux n'a rien
réglé
on voit que finalement ça n'a pas réglé
la question du financement des retraites
et que l'on est obligé déjà d'envisager
de nouvelles mesures nous sommes le seul
pays d'europe en fin de compte
accumulée a ajouté la durée
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
et l'allongement de la jalle auquel on
peut partir en retraite et cela va
porter préjudice à de nombreux salariés
qui ont eu des carrières particulière et
qui en fin de compte vont voir baisser
de façon très très forte
ben leur pension et leur capacité à
avoir du pouvoir d'achat la retraite
les syndicats ont déjà protesté contre
cette annonce
ils dénoncent eux aussi une double peine
le gouvernement devrait publier le
décret avant la fin de l'année 2011
les syndicats qui promettent aussi de
retourner dans la rue comme on l'a vu il
ya quelques mois
tam en 2010 ce moment on votait cette
retraite ici au sénat ça vous fait peur
cette rentrée chaude que promet de
promettre les syndicats tous les ans
quel que soit le gouvernement on a
toujours 10 septembre c'est toujours une
rentrée chaude une rentrée sociale
puisque effectivement c'est la rentrée
pour tout le monde
il faut la réforme des retraites et ce
décret qui sera pris en application
d'une disposition de la loi 2003 c'est
pas une surprise c'est absolument pas
une surprise c'est la réforme des
retraites telle qu'elle a été adoptée
l'année dernière ou en début d'année
n'était pas prévu au programme de
nicolas sarkozy c'est vrai c'était pas
l'engagement qu'ils avaient pris devant
les français quand il était candidat
sauf que ce qui n'était pas prévu non
plus c'est aussi la crise et donc la
crise a aggravé les déficits et
notamment sur le système de financement
de travaux section sociale moi je suis
député européen je peux vous dire que
nous sommes un des rares pays à ne pas
avoir effectivement augmenté cet
allongement
cet allongement de la durée de
cotisation on doit être on était sans
doute le dernier pays
donc faut juste s'adapter aux évolutions
et de la vie et de la société
donc la réforme des retraites sera une
réforme permanente plus on va travailler
plus on va donner que c'est quand même
extrêmement dur d'avoir toutes ces
annonces dans une même année notamment
ses 41 ans et demi même s'ils sont si
soit issu de la loi de 2003 on les avait
annoncés simplement pour 2020 non c'est
l'attachement qu'il s'était fixé pour
2020 c'est quand même je crois que la
loi de 2003 indiqué 2012 de mémoire mais
mais ce qu'il faut faire c'est que comme
d'ailleurs je vous dis comme la réforme
des retraites qu'ils n'étaient pas
annoncées dans le programme du candidat
à l'élection présidentielle mais la
réforme des retraites c'est bien la
matière qui est sans cesse en évolution
d'abord la démographie on a une
démographie effectivement en terme de
population active qui diminue nous
sommes à pas loin de 2 cotisant deux
actifs pour un retraité
nous en serons plus que dans quelques
années à un et demi pour ne pas dire un
donc forcément il faut sauvegarder notre
système de protection sociale qui est
fondé sur la solidarité et ce système de
protection sociale qui fondée sur la
solidarité ça permet notamment à ceux
qui peuvent travailler ou ceux qui ont
un peu plus de moyens et solidaire
ceux qui sont les plus vulnérables les
plus fragiles ou ceux qui ont plus de
difficultés qu'ont eu plus de
difficultés à travailler
donc moi je trouve que c'est à l'honneur
de la france de près de préserver
protéger ce système fondé sur la
solidarité
allez on continue la semaine avec
toujours le mardi les questions au
gouvernement l'occasion pour les tout
nouveaux ministre de se faire les dents
face aux questions des députés
ainsi jean leonetti nommé à la faveur du
remaniement de la semaine dernière
ministre des affaires européennes treize
ans à son siège de député et pour la
première fois au banc des ministres
car lascaray thomas souliers l'ont suivi
en ce jour en novembre dernier il avait
espéré la présidence du groupe ump à
l'assemblée
le poste lui avait alors échappé au
profit de christian jacob et je me fais
aujourd'hui le voilà ministre délégué
aux affaires européennes
une nouvelle situation qu'il ne réalise
pas encore
j'ai encore des des petits réflexes de
député sans revenant de l'avion ce matin
je disais dépêchons nos pour la réunion
de groupe et on m'a fait remarquer que
la fin de la réunion de groupe il y
avait plus de conférence de presse du
vice président et qu'il valait mieux
venir directement au ministère quand
vous à peine une minute vous retourner
non je continue à marcher droit et a pas
bougé enfin on doit s'y habituer le
suppose et après 14 ans passés sur les
bancs des députés jean leonetti se
retrouvent enfin sur le devant de la
scène
ma question s'adresse à monsieur jean
leonetti ministre chargé des affaires
européennes
monsieur le ministre le 1er juillet la
pologne vient de prendre la présidence
de l'union européenne dans un contexte
difficile de crise financière économique
et politique
quelles initiatives allez vous prendre
pour accompagner la pologne qui promet
une grande présidence de l'union
européenne
quelle est votre feuille de route
première interpellation aux questions au
gouvernement derniers ajustements et
premières réponses devant le regard
bienveillant et les autres ministres et
le concitoyens veulent une europe qui
nous protège ambitieuse concrète cette
europe concrète
c'est notre objectif jean leonetti garde
la tête froide ne devrait rester à la
tête de son ministère qu'une dizaine de
mois présidentielle oblige
rachida dati ce ce premier jour de
ministre pour vous devant les députés de
c'est un jour de mai 2007 vous sont s'en
souvenait encore de cette première
question on la vit avec appréhension
cette première question adressée par un
député
oui moi j'ai moi j'ai beaucoup aimé les
questions d'actualité et l'opposition
d'ailleurs me posais beaucoup plus que
la majorité mais j'aime ça d'abord c'est
c'est très interactif c'est très
politique c'est comme c'est très court
ah ouais moi j'adore ça
non moi je faisais effectivement je
faisais ça sans notes parce que d'abord
les sujets du stis me passionne et c'est
vrai que j'ai fait ça avec avec beaucoup
de conviction et beaucoup de force et
d'énergie pour répondre directement à
l'opposition font rentrer dedans parce
que là où se rendent pas compte les
téléspectateurs soit parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le brouhaha donc nous les dans le
bois parfois son temps plein par les
nous mêmes il faut avoir faut avoir les
idées claires
et puis il ya les d'une seule traite
voir donc moi j'ai beaucoup plus
médiatique de jean leonetti qu'est donc
ministre des affaires européennes on le
connaît plus comme spécialiste des
questions de bioéthique est ce qu il
va réussir ce que ça va être dur pour
lui de s'attaquer à des dossiers aussi
technique sur l'europe c'est d'abord
c'est un ami vraiment s'entend très bien
et d'ailleurs
moi je l'avais beaucoup soutenu sur la
loi sur justement sur l'euthanasie sur
le sur la fin de vie il avait vraiment
fait un rapport exceptionnel notamment
très équilibré sur la lorraine est a
priori pas 300 domaines
oui mais quand vous êtes parlementaire
c'est un homme intelligent
si vous avez une bonne équipe il a des
collaborateurs et puis à la fois les
questions de bioéthique c'est pas un
question ne s'est pas uniquement une
question franco français ces processus
on va l'attendre priori de 9,0
il connaît les quais les sujets
européens
en plus il ya eu d'autres débattre quand
vous êtes parlementaires ont participé à
d'autres départs c'est parce que vous
êtes spécialisé dans une question que
vous n'êtes pas compétents dans les
autres domaines donc moi je n'ai aucune
inquiétude mais très vite sur le succès
de jean leonetti comme l'isaf européenne
pratiquement cinq ministres des affaires
européennes sous la législature de
françois fillon
ça fait pas peut-être beaucoup dans un
terme
doute avec le parlement européen n'est
pas un problème notamment que le
parlement européen on ne voit pas comme
un pays instable en la matière on
comprend un peu leur talent est d'abord
si non si les députés européens devaient
porter un jugement c'est sur les
présidence tournante tous les six mois
on change de présidence de l'union
européenne c'est plutôt ça qui n'est pas
stable ou qui n'est pas constant c'était
toute la volonté du traité de lisbonne
de m cette présidence plus constante
plus stable de 2 ans et demi mais au
départ rappelez vous quand on a débattu
de ce traité qui était le mini traité
qui était cette fois monsieur
constitution rejetée c'est de dire qu'on
fait qu'on supprime ses présidences
tournantes et puis finalement on n'a pas
réussi
donc on l'a trouvé un compromis comme
toujours c'est ce qu'ont à dix
présidences tournantes et une présidence
stable de 2 ans et demi donc d'ailleurs
on le voit bien la difficulté de
l'articulation du conseil européen et
puis cette présidence de l'union
européenne
donc si on avait un problème de
stabilité ce serait plutôt à ce niveau
là que ça devrait effectivement se jouer
le contre était encore un mot de
monsieur leonetti faisait sûrement
entendu parler les critiques sur le
bidouillage centriste lors du
remaniement
on aurait ainsi remercier monsieur
leonetti de ne pas avoir soutenu jean
louis borloo dans sa dissidence
ça vous semble une bonne analyse c'est
la voûte c'est pas les miennes
récompense nommée jean leonetti avec ou
sans ça d'ailleurs vous l'avez rappelé
il souhaitait président de groupe
il n'a pas gardé ni d'amertume ni
d'aigreur voilà c'est un homme politique
courageux responsable avec des
convictions vous pourriez vous avoir la
tentation jean louis borloo il c'est
marrant c'est à dire que ce genre de
questions nous les poser à monsieur
juppé pourquoi pas si vous voulez posera
monsieur fut la réponse est je viens de
reviendra après pour vous attendez quoi
j'ai répondu non mais si vous posez des
questions de répondre non aussi c'est
non mais vous poser des questions et on
n'est pas dans le gadget
la politique c'est pas du gadget pour
moi je suis pas engagée sur des sujets
lourds et on assure que rama yade votre
ancien collègue au gouvernement je vous
dis
rejoint posera la question à monsieur
raffarin qui dans cette noble maison
poserait à monsieur juppé puis après je
vous répondrais je la politique c'est
pas du gadget pas comme ça ma conception
du monde et pas des questions mercredi
les élections sénatoriales
on en parle beaucoup et les approches
chaque parties négocient et la tension
commence à monter
rue de solférino le parti socialiste
continue de négocier avec ses alliés
notamment les radicaux avec il pourrait
peut-être trouvé un accord pour la
droite à paris la tension est toujours
aussi forte
jean françois copé le patron de l'ump
est fait et pourtant de tout faire pour
ramener le calme mais les décidant
persiste les explications de sandra
cerqueira les investitures ump ou quand
paris devient grand échiquier où chacun
avance ses pions
sous le regard de l'hôte de l'elysée
pour les sénatoriales c'est sûr chantal
jouanno conduira la liste en septembre
mais les égos froissé ne l'acceptent pas
pierre charon ancien conseiller du chef
de l'état et certains maires ump de la
capitale mèneront une liste dissidente
ceux qui ne respecteront pas le choix
alors qui s'intitule de notre bord alors
qu'il dise partageait nos valeurs feront
courir un risque énorme à la majorité
sénatoriale et par ricochet au président
de la république
la liste de pierre charon est en mesure
d'emporter un siège côté législatives le
match fillon dati ne s'annonce pas plus
simple enjeu la deuxième circonscription
celle des 5e 6e et 7e arrondissements
convoité par rachida dati face aux
rumeurs d'un parachutage de françois
fillon
l'ancienne garde des sceaux se dit
déterminé à se présenter aux
législatives
elle demande à être respecté par ses
alliés réponse cinglante de l'ump
du côté de la rue de la boétie jean
françois copé reste pour l'heure
silencieux il n'en reste pas moins un
proche de rachida dati est un rival de
fillon certains parient déjà sur un deal
entre les deux hommes d'ici à 2012 à
copé le parti à fillon paris ils ont le
temps ensuite de se combattre en 2010
est acheté à tirer c'est que vous ne
soutenez pas la liste officielle de
chantal jouanno vous avez entendu jean
claude gaudin le patron des sénateurs
ump qui dit les responsables de cette
défaite auront des comptes à rendre
sentez visé
non c'est clair ça veut dire quoi il n'y
aura pas de défaite ou au contraire vous
êtes sûr que la liste qu'on n'est pas
bien seront aujourd'hui pour armer
rayonner un siège de se donner un
scrutin mais c'est pas une désignation
donc on verra le l'issue du vote
est ce que dans ces élections
sénatoriales qui ont lieu est ce qu'il
se cache quelque chose de plus important
derrière et ce qui se cache comme on
l'avait dit dans ce sujet les élections
législatives par exemple est une
bataille pour renato rial sont à part
lui initiatives sont à paris est une
bataille comme l'ump paris pour
l'instant c'est un foutoir des raisons
ce qui veut dire pourquoi pourquoi c'est
un foutoir pourrait nous expliquer ce
que c'est vrai que pour l'instant il n'y
a pas d'équipé pas de projet n'est pas
leader ship donc
donc voilà c'est tout moi c'est le
constat que je fais et pour les
sénatoriales la liste de chantal jouanno
mais ne vous convient pas il y en a été
désigné par la commission nationale
d'investiture de l'ump elle était là la
liste a été choisie par la commission
nationale d'investiture le visuel du
solde donc nicolas sarkozy lui la
commission nationale d'investiture que
j'ai choisi cette liste on verra à
l'issue du scrutin en septembre
bon sur les législatives à paris on dit
que françois fillon pourrait être
candidat sur le même secteur que vous
dans la même circonscription qui dit
pourquoi pas et là il vous l'a dit il ya
eu des discussions au touquet monsieur
fillon monsieur fillon vous l'a dit des
journalistes avec monsieur fillon qui
aujourd'hui pour être candidat il
faisait les races coupe pour être
candidat à paris vous n'y croyez même
été candidat à paris aux candidats aux
législatives
candidat à paris un message ans et rien
n'en sais rien mais si vous avez un
scoop c'est bien si des gens les volent
ont dû aussi lui vous l'a dit
sélectionner des candidats ni candidat
ou sur la séquence cription qu'elle n'a
pas dit qu'il était candidat aux
législatives dans la circonscription je
suis élu comme maire d'arrondissement
voilà c'est tout il a dit qu'il
attendait mais on attendait n'en faut
être prêt si vous êtes défendre
l'intérêt pour l'instant l'a dit mais
elle n'a pas dit pour l'instant ce n'est
pas ses préoccupations et ça n'est pas
d'actualité
voilà personne de cash en tout cas
pierre lellouche qui est un ami de
françois fillon
non il est élu de paris n'a pas caché
qu'il serait candidat donc mais que
monsieur lellouche une un avis d'autres
choses monsieur fillon a dit que ça
n'était pas sa préoccupation je crois
que monsieur fillon a dit à monsieur
lellouche qui n'était pas très content
des propos qu'il a pu tenir sur ce sujet
on voit n'oubliez pas il n'y a pas
d'autres commentaires à faire pour sa
fille en ferait un bon maire de paris
j'en sais rien moi pas d'avis moi j'ai
pas d'avis là dessus ce sont c'est les
parisiens ils veulent quoi on qu'on
s'occupe d'eux qu'on ait des projets
qu'on faisait les préoccupations du
parisien c'est le transport le logement
les modes de garde d'enfants et françois
fillon oui nous était c'est marrant
facile des raccourcis faciles non je
vous dis les parisiens ils attendent ils
sont pas c'est comme pour les
socialistes
alors ils sont pas là en train de s'en
fiche des bagarres des gosses et qu'est
ce qu'on leur propose et les parisiens
vous arrivez pas la veille pour dire
voilà ce que je vous propose est un
ça c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
une élection alors qu'il faut aussi
respecter les parisiens comme a dit
d'ailleurs claude goasguen c'est pas une
préfecture paris
si encore une personne qu'on élit sur un
projet sur des idées sur leur
connaissance du terrain privé dès qu'il
vaut mieux être maire du 7e
arrondissement pour ça a été très dur
dispo ça a été une bataille pour le fait
que le début voilà je suis ravi d'être
d'avoir été élu j'ai été élu avec 10
points de plus que mon prédécesseur que
d'ailleurs et qui s'était pas mon
prédécesseur c'était martine aurillac la
dernière qui avait été vue puisqu'elle
avait dans l'eau potable avant de nice
la mairie ensuite à quelqu'un d'autre
mais voilà donc c'est une élection moi
j'ai été je suis fier et honoré d'être
au maire du 7e arrondissement et je
m'occupe comme conseiller de paris
également de tous les sujets tous les
grands projets parisiens ce matin j'ai
eu une réunion avec bertrand delanoë sur
des projets parisiens on discute de tout
avec bertrand delanoë sur des sujets
effectivement qui concerne paris allez
on va passer au jeudi et l'ump qui
planche sur le thème de l'immigration
en ce jeudi l'ump se réunit pour une
convention sur l'immigration sur fond de
débat sur la binationalité invité le
ministre de l'intérieur claude guéant
persiste et signe sur l'immigration
légale
un esb étions l'immigration c'est un
sujet compliqué pour l'ump et qu'on le
ministre de l'intérieur saint vit ça ne
me semble y fit rien le premier devoir
c'est bien sûr qu'au ministre de
l'intérieur de lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière
mais il serait irresponsable de ma part
de ne pas agir pour réduire
l'immigration légale dans un pays où
l'opinion publique s'alarme des
résultats de la politique d'intégration
une prise de position loin de satisfaire
l social de l'ump
de toute façon ne sera très difficile de
diminuer l'immigration légale pour de
multiples raisons que ce soit des
raisons professionnelles quand tu prends
que président de la république a
souhaité une immigration choisie donc
professionnel et que quelques mois après
monsieur guillon revienne sur ses
orientations de prison a répliqué trouve
ça aberrant c'est incohérent
à l'opposé de cette sensibilité claude
goasguen et
lionnel luca en bonne place à la tribune
ce dernier a menacé de démissionner de
son poste de secrétaire national à
l'immigration
il a été rattrapé par jean françois copé
le secrétaire général lui a promis ce
qu'il voulait un débat sur la
binationalité à l'automne thème loin de
faire l'unanimité à l'ump mais très
important pour les députés de la droite
populaire c'est un sujet de réflexion
qu'on ne peut pas évacué d'un revers de
main il ya des pays qui n'ont pas la
binationalité la double nationalité
comment font-ils pour survivre alors que
nous ne pourrions pas vivre sans la
double nationalité et à travers la
double nationalité et poser la question
de savoir est ce que un citoyen français
est obligé d'être multi car tout
simplement avec une carte d'identité
trouver le juste milieu entre la droite
populaire et les députés plus modérée
difficiles défis que devra relever jean
françois copé au moment de présenter la
contribution de l'ump au projet
présidentiel alors réduire l'immigration
légale c'est le nouveau credo de claude
guéant l'a rappelé à plusieurs reprises
cela vous semble une bonne piste
c'est c'est de dire que dans un contexte
d'une part de crise ouvre le chômage
extrêmement élevé
de fait et l'immigration légale veut
être réduite puisque l'immigration
légale de travail j'entends dire que si
vous êtes en période de crise s'il ya un
chômage élevé c'est sûr qu'on a moins
besoin d'une main-d'oeuvre étrangère
c'est parce que devant le medef
mais qui dit que cette main d'oeuvre est
un parce que je suis en train de dire
c'est que si vous êtes en période de
crise vous avez un taux de chômage qui
est élevé vous avez vous fait moins
appel à une main d'oeuvre étrangère
simplement ce qu'il faut savoir que ces
sujets je les connais bien c'est de dire
que l'immigration légale du travail
souvent elle se fait sur des postes très
particulier des saisonniers par exemple
c'est dans le sud de la france
il y a des comme ça des professions sur
lequel ya pas de formation particulière
où on ne s'accouplent plus cher
finalement de créer des formations pour
certains emplois on préfère avoir une
main d'oeuvre étrangère provisoire qui
viennent effectivement pourvoir des
postes qui ne sont pas pourvus qu'ils
sont nécessaires notamment l'agriculture
française une fois qu'ils ont terminé
leur contrat ils retournent dans leur
pays d'origine
c'est immigration là ne peut pas être
réduite mais donc c'est pour ça que
c'est un équilibre à avoir entre les
besoins de notre pays mais aussi le le
contexte économique français mais il ya
aussi des emplois qui ne sont pas
pourvus aussi en france sur lequel nous
devrions peut-être plus intéresser les
demandeurs d'emploi ou revoir les
filières de formation donc ça n'est pas
aberrant mais de dire que l'immigration
légale du travail sera réduite à zéro
c'est illusoire
c'est pas possible d'ailleurs
l'allemagne qui très récemment a fait
appel à une main d'oeuvre étrangère
notamment sur les emplois dits qualifiés
et aujourd'hui je crois que la ministre
de l'allemand de l'économie ou du
travail a dit en disant qu'il y avait un
million d'emplois non pourvus en
allemagne est d'ailleurs le coût des
emplois non pourvus a coûté à l'économie
je crois quelques milliards d'euros
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont perdu en
compétitivité du fait de ne pas avoir la
main d'or il est bourré qui pourrait
effectivement encore plus augmenté cette
compétitivité allemande donc
l'immigration légale du travail est voué
à exister
ensuite vous pouvez la moduler est alors
plus - mais tout ça n'est pas c'est pas
statique
voilà vous êtes intervenu lors de cette
convention de l'ump
le fossile de la droite populaire
notamment à propos de la binationalité
cela vous semble aujourd'hui utile
d'avoir ce débat quand le débat a
commencé à être énoncées j'ai dit moi ça
ne me gêne absolument pas complice
débattent de la binationalité parce que
si on est pas si on ne débat pas des
choses on de enfin quand le sujet sur la
table qu'il y avait des choses c'est pas
forcément la préoccupation première des
français
mais dès lors on en parle et on dire
nous ne faut pas en parler on donne le
sentiment qu effectivement ce sujet il
est sensible et dangereux où il est
qu'on devrait pas effectivement qu'on va
sortir des choses horribles
moi je suis d'accord pour qu'on mette
sur la table débat sur la binationalité
parce qu'on va se rendre compte que ça
ne concerne pas majoritairement les
maghrébins où les africains parce que je
pense que ce débat pour certains dans
leur inconscient ont le sentiment que si
on débat de la binationalité salle
concernerait que cette catégorie
finalement des binationaux front
national
me fais c'est pour ça que moi j'aimerais
qu'on le mette sur la table et on se
rendra compte de quoi que finalement
pratiquement tous les européens sont
binationaux
jean est bien où la vie les finalités
bout rachida dati mme banon pourquoi je
ne sais pas ce que vous êtes née d'un
père marocain et de mère âgée souffrant
c'est aujourd'hui oui oui non mais lors
de la question
voilà d'accord mais s'est donc posé les
yeux sinon tous étaient proposés à
raison de les mettre sur la table dès
aujourd'hui avant avant l'élection
présidentielle ça sert de débats pour
l'après quoi je trouve que qu'un parti
politique si c'est un lieu de débat on
doit débattre de tout mais aussi mois
d'ailleurs je veux déploré ce matin dans
une interview pour faire attention de ne
pas débattre uniquement pour caricaturer
stigmatiser montré du doigt moi ça m'a
gêné le débat sur le rsa fassent ce
qu'il en est sorti qu'on débatte du rsa
des prestations sociales de la
protection sociale en france
oui ça serait bien on va d'abord en
démontrera que notre pays est
extrêmement généreux et extrêmement
protecteurs ensuite qu'on montre du
doigt un million et quelques 2 de
français qui sont dans la fiq
difficultés dans la souffrance
en période de crise en les qualifiant de
cancer de la société ce constat un peu
indécent en période de crise mais lutter
contre la fraude aux prestations
sociales
c'est une nécessité parce
qu'effectivement c'est comme ça aussi
qu'on ne suspectera jamais personne âgée
de 28 ans parler d'un autre sujet au
sénat une prime a créé la polémique la
question a décidé d'attribuer 3531 euros
aux sénateurs un rattrapage exceptionnel
qui correspond à des indemnités de frais
de représentation
gérard larcher explique que cette prime
n'avait pas été revalorisé depuis trois
ans plusieurs sénateurs ont refusé de
l'apercevoir au nom du contexte de crise
face à la fronde le président du sénat
est obligé de faire machine arrière les
explications et les écarts ni
pour mettre des sénateurs dans
l'embarras aujourd'hui il fallait poser
une toute petite question
comme plusieurs de vos collègues vous
pensé à rendre la prime exceptionnelle
ça veut dire non
ça ne veut pas dire non
ça veut dire oui ça ne veut pas dire oui
je m'occuperai les finances de l'état ne
fait pas partie qui vont la rendre car
plusieurs sénateurs ont décidé de rendre
cette prime exceptionnelle de plus de
3000 euros octroyée par le sénat parmi
lesquels la socialiste nicole bricq
remisez coup ça y est vous
et surtout et c'est symbolique le
président de la commission des finances
du sénat
enfin moi je passe mon temps
a demandé au gouvernement de faire des
efforts pour réduire la dépense publique
pour réduire les déficits publics
et voilà que nous nous laissons aller à
de telles pratiques c'est injuste c'est
choquant c'est une provocation et donc
je demande que cela soit corrigé le plus
vite possible
ça arrive à un très mauvais moment par
rapport à aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
donc je le dis très simplement je pense
que c'est une erreur
j'apprends qu'un mouvement se dessine
pour renoncer à cette à cette prime je
trouve que c'est une bonne idée
vous allez leur loin de ce mouvement bah
oui cet après midi même le ministre du
travail met de l'huile sur le feu est ce
que c'est parce que c'est la sphère des
parlementaires maintenant je vais vous
dire il ya des sénateurs qu'il a fait
tout ce remue ménage est parvenue
jusqu'aux présidents du sénat qui en a
pris acte
il indique dans une lettre aux questeurs
qu'il souhaite une annulation pure et
simple de cette prime aux bouffes la
rachida dati ces sénateurs ils ont bien
fait finalement d'annuler cette demande
de prime par la décision a été prise il
ya plus de commentaires à faire au
niveau européen ça n'existe pas ça parce
que j'ai cru comprendre c'était une
prime supplémentaire qui arrivait
s'ajouter à d'autres frais on n'a pas eu
de prime supplémentaire je confirme
c'est beaucoup de nous quitter
c'était la dernière émission avant l'été
rachida dati merci d'y avoir participé
et on profite de l'occasion bien sûr
michael pour remercier sa verrière ogec
et l'honneur picot chaque semaine nous
accompagne pour la préparation de cette
émission merci donc à elles deux quant à
nous il est vrai qu'en ce moment ça se
retrouve là c'est l'année prochaine
au revoir